So I'm going to tell you the story of a woman who was truly remarkable.
She was four years old when our story begins in 1871.
She's Polish, born in Warsaw, which has just been occupied by the Russians,
and back then, nobody would ever have guessed that little Maria Sklodowska
would one day become the most famous woman in the world.
Should work a bit more.
Autumn, before the frost, come up in spring when the winter's past and gone.
But, Marie, how did you learn to read?
That's all. It isn't terribly difficult, Papa.
That on purpose?
Children, we're going to share a secret.
Going to tell you about the history of our land, Poland.
It's not allowed, you know.
Do you want to know it?
Yes, yes.
Marie, go ahead.
Alexander II, Tsar of Russia, won't let Poland live in freedom.
We live under his tyranny, but...
Hey, children, it's the inspector.
So in class, I guess.
Yes, inspector, every hour each day.
And Russian history, you teach it?
Yes, inspector.
All right, we'll see.
You, who rules us?
His Majesty Alexander II, Tsar of all Russias.
And exactly who am I?
His Excellency, the inspector.
It's me.
Very good.
Must have been a stone you tripped.
again. Tsar Alexander II is a tyrant, but one day our country will be free. The Russians
won't permit women to go to the university. You should go to France, except foreigners,
including women. I know, but it costs a great deal. I'll work and send you money. It'd be
better if you go. It's not practical. I'm 17, you're 20. You'll get a medical degree
and then you'll help. Mary Sklodowska remained in Poland working and sending money for seven
and finally it was her turn to go blankets sheets and tea did you bring the
tea costs a lot in Paris yes Papa and the sausages and nice warm sweaters and a
good winter coat chemistry books yes yes they're all here belong to me sir it's
gonna cost you a pretty cool pick and you have to pay the two rubles of the
mattress the ruble for the large package there as 60 topics for this one a large
You know, a two rubles. That makes altogether... But, sir, I haven't the money. I'm a student. Regulations are regulations. So you owe exactly. Please, sir, I ask you, please. No, no, no. What's the trouble here? She has far too much baggage. Look at it all. And there. And that. And all that. And she refuses to pay. Well, what about it? Well, I need it all. I haven't any money. I'm going to study in Paris. Ah, Paris. France. A land of liberty.
and of science.
You're being too strict.
Authorization to carry baggage, no charge.
Signal departure.
Thank you.
Go on.
But I...
That's an order.
Arrived in Paris.
Ah, Paris, where a great scientist,
Louis Pasteur, was coming to the end of his days.
Rolls in the science course at the Sorbonne
and very quickly realizes how far she is behind her classmates.
For many years to come,
she will devote herself entirely to her work.
Physical scientist awarded by the University of Paris.
First, Mary Sklodowska.
It's true.
You intend to study higher mathematics? Quite unusual.
Of course, at this time, there were hardly any women at the university.
Their rights were still a long way off.
A woman factory worker was paid one-fourth the salary of a man doing the same work.
Examination and integral calculus.
Mathematics from the University of Paris to, first, Marie Sklodowska.
My congratulations, mademoiselle.
Observed a curious phenomenon, these crystals.
Pierre Curie, I'd like to introduce Marie Sklodowska.
She's come from Poland to work with us.
- You were saying, Pierre? - Well, I don't remember.
- Me? - Mademoiselle, I have brought you a gift.
- Monsieur Curie, you really shouldn't. - Booked by Zola.
- Late. You've missed the last train home, Pierre. - Oh, it doesn't matter, Marie. I'll walk home.
I like walking. It gives me a chance to think about things. Well, good night.
- Pierre Curie walked all the way home, on the outskirts of Paris, 15 kilometers away.
- He was a kind of a nut. - Not at all. Pierre and Marie, well, they weren't ordinary people.
people they loved above all learning about science but they loved each other all the same oh yes they
loved each other you know marie i've observed crystals that produce an electricity it's
interesting did you pierre well i think i found a sort of earth that emits light pretty interesting
too oh the lovebirds words of endearment it makes me cry let's not watch them uranium isn't the only
element that gives off these radiations yes and there must exist a symmetry in nature linking
magnetism and electricity.
Juice for you.
There's nothing like it.
At the same time,
another scientist, Henri Becquerel,
performed an experiment.
A tube containing uranium
was wrapped in aluminum
and it made an impression
on a photographic plate.
Monsieur Becquerel,
you were right.
Uranium does emit radiation
and it went through the aluminum.
It's the nature of this radiation.
And there we are.
It meant the study of radioactivity
started there and then.
Care?
Idea for my doctoral thesis.
A doctorate?
Well, it won't be very easy for a woman.
I've never liked doing easy things.
My subject is those curious rays that were found by Becquerel.
Yes, the subject is a good one, but it's not easy, Marie.
Pierre, there has to be an element, a substance still unknown that gives off more radiation than uranium.
Think so?
I'm certain, and I'll tell you why.
The uranium radiation seems to have a variable factor, depending on the degree of purity.
Yes, but it is a single element in its pure form.
However, I have found that pitchblend contains traces of some substance that has a vector of radiation far exceeding our experiments with uranium, another element.
Anyway, you're in your element.
Sometimes I wonder if you take me seriously.
Let's say we're both immersed in our work.
So, according to Madame Curie, there exists an element still unknown which emits spontaneously a strong radiation.
That's not possible after all.
Well, I mean, it's a woman who claims to have found it.
This radioactive element is found in a very special soil pitch blend.
It exists in Austria. We must have some here.
We'll need great quantities. We'll need a place to put it.
The question is where?
I think I know where.
My friends, this is all I can offer you.
As you can see, it's not in good condition.
But the government doesn't help scientists very much.
Just won't.
That's all I've got.
It will do us very well, Monsieur Schultz. We're obliged to you.
Pierre and Marie are going to work for four years in conditions that are absolutely unbelievable.
Coffee, dear?
It's all for now. Break. I can see you're exhausted.
Marie, we have to stop and rest.
No, no. Now our objective is close. We'll go on.
You said you wanted radium to have a nice color. Look.
There it is. So pretty radium.
Yes, Marie.
Do you realize I worked out the statistics?
We have processed more than 10 tons of pitch blend to obtain one gram of radium.
Yes, but the gram is worth a fortune.
And I wonder, suppose we took out a patent, we would have what we need to carry on our own projects, our work, our laboratory.
No, Pierre, no. We have to publish freely, completely, the results of our research.
All of humanity should be able to benefit from our discovery, even the poorest.
You'll do well, you'll see.
The University of Paris has never awarded a doctorate to a woman. It's unprecedented, and a foreigner, well.
Sure, we will judge the candidate on merit and not upon sex, and certainly not upon nationality.
Madame, tell us how you isolated the radium.
It is a complicated technique.
I began by mixing the unique raw material, pitch blend, and then I went on to...
Explain exactly what is this radium, madame.
It's an element heretofore unknown.
It emits spontaneously certain radiation as well as heat.
I called this property radioactivity.
Radioactivity? Nonsense, such a thing can...
Thank you, madame.
The University of Paris awards you the degree of doctorate in the physical sciences
with special mention, highest distinction.
On behalf of the jury, I congratulate you.
It really is the last straw.
Why not put her in the Academy of Sciences next?
You poor fellow, you would do well to learn a few lessons.
Not from you, Baron.
Oh, no, no, no.
Really that hard for a woman to get a diploma?
Now, think about it.
At the time, not one other woman had a doctorate in science.
Two women weren't even allowed to vote.
The celebrated Octave Mirbeau even wrote,
Woman has one role in the universe, perpetuate the species.
Yes, but why, Maestro?
They're women who had companies, they're professors, government ministers.
Today they are.
But only now, in the present, until quite recently, man dominated.
Hey son, it's the man who's the stronger, right?
Yeah, but perhaps not the most intelligent, as we all see.
I'm glad it's not like that anymore.
It's getting better.
But there's still progress to be made.
Sensational news!
Three French scientists awarded the Nobel Prize.
It's all here!
The prize is 70,000 francs.
We'll be able to live better.
and equip our laboratory.
My friends, you've just been awarded the Osiris Prize, 50,000 francs.
Kaz Prize, you got it.
Good work.
Langevin, what good news have you brought?
The Gagné Prize. That's right, you won.
The Davy Gold Medal is awarded to you.
It's the highest scientific award in all of England.
The United States is specially arranged for you?
Exactly how did you discover radium?
No, no photographs for the times.
no race horses named after me no no no banquets tube of radium in the pocket of
my lab coat get this you see yes I've observed this effect of radium we might
try using it as a cure against cancer yes well we have to try it did you got my
leg of lamb the lab absolutely certainly occasion is over now tomorrow I return
to Paris I'll join you in a couple of days ladies and gentlemen wish to offer
I suggest that Madame Curie take over the chair of physics that Professor Curie held at the Sorbonne.
That's preposterous. No woman has ever been admitted to teach at university level.
Oh, be quiet. Madame Curie is named Professor at the Sorbonne.
And believe me, that nomination was for the period Front Page News a victory.
... of a member to the Academy of Sciences. The candidates are...
Marcel Brouin, Edward Branly, and, uh, Madame Marie Curie.
in the academy. It's a splendid joke.
Yes, that one. What name does she use?
Curie? Yes, but her real name is...
Sloshla... Slopla...
In any case, her husband, Pierre Curie,
really discovered radium, not her.
She is a great scientist, Polish and Catholic.
What more do you want?
At the lake. But are you sure?
No woman in the academy.
Gentlemen, we shall proceed to the vote.
What happened to the lights?
Sir Adroit Branly is elected with 30 votes.
Madame Marie Curie obtains 28 votes.
Monsieur Brouin, one vote.
Now they're imagining.
No, women in the Academy of Sciences, the election has been held.
That same year at the Academy of Sciences, but in Sweden this time.
Gentlemen, the Academy of Sciences in Stockholm awards the Nobel Prize in Chemistry to Madame Marie Curie.
1913, Marie is exhausted.
She spends her vacation in Switzerland where she meets a remarkable young man, Albert Einstein.
1914, the First World War.
The madness of mankind.
Curie, what an honor. But do come in, please do.
I have very little time, madam. I have come to ask you for a favor.
Why, certainly, whatever you'd like.
I simply want that.
But it's my brand new car. I was about to go off shopping with it.
I mean, you see, I'm sorry. It's something I need.
And France needs it more to save her soldiers, madame.
I, uh, oh, go ahead.
Jean, please drive that car to the Institute at once.
Thank you for your generosity. Your car will be returned to you, of course.
after the war.
I could hardly say no.
These cars.
Repaint them?
Yes, gray with a red cross.
Dynamo, an x-ray machine, screens, photographic equipment, a cable, curtains, oh and don't
forget the protective gloves.
The Dynamo, run the cable to the tent and mask all openings, the x-ray machine, the photographic
plates.
You see Doctor, the fracture line is clear.
A splint should do it.
Thank you Madame Curie.
There aren't men enough.
Women will do very well as radiologists and can drive ambulances.
course mother you see ladies by using x-rays we can see the skeletons and any
fractures now this is going to be the procedure to start the engine you turn
the crank she did high into the left puts it in first gear you begin with
that one the rule you first disengage the clutch landed now drive straight
ahead nice and slow curies they're going to the front to save our brave soldiers
you know we ought to give women the vote in the monster women mr. Zingray
where is the world headed thanks to Marie Curie a million x-rays were
carried out, and many lives were saved. She made a great contribution. In 1921, she undertakes
an exhausting trip to the United States to bring back a quantity of radium, a gift from
the United States to the great scientist. Pictures and receptions, even at the White House. It
was truly a triumph. On her return to Paris, a scientist is there for the radium, and only
two reporters are waiting for her. The reporters ask questions of profound importance.
Your preference, madam, in the match between Carpentier and Dempsey.
In 1934, Marie Curie will die exhausted.
She had pernicious anemia.
It was diagnosed for at the time they didn't know that radiation could be deadly.
Humanity owes a very great deal to this woman.
She deserves to live in our hearts.
Vagabond de tailleur.
Voici que l'homme décolle.
Il va quitter le sol.
Mais parce qu'il s'envole firmament.